[Music]
re I have a
sense of speed
. I'm a biter rar. I'm a jg. I'm a
4 year old
receive driver.
[Music]
me This is the one
who started the racer
.
I started racing with the thought
that
I gave a racing cart on my 3rd birthday and put it on
it.
Now I can do it with a way of finishing running that really does not lose to anything.
Inami has won an innumerable number of 22 wins in a race that is too big to run out of water.
I felt it when I saw it, so the next step was f fishing
. It was just that I gave a faster machine to this sea
. Now I think it's difficult for the
opposite sex.  Hmm
-4
Downforce Musicing Speed
k there aren't any kids in the world who are in elementary school and ride the f3.
I don't think it was, and
as a parent, I just support what my child wants to do.
[Music]
I'll be a little more careful when I say things that can be stopped.
-That's why I'm going to quit the racing driver tomorrow, so it
's the scale that she does what she wants to do as hard as she wants.
That is
[Music]